passenger name record the system for
collecting and retaining air passenger
details is being hotly debated again
with new proposals despite the
controversy for one rupee the overall
benefits are clear this instrument that
are not perfect but they so far have
been useful to prevent to save lives in
Europe but concern surrounds extension
of P&R to internal european flights and
a 30-day limit for deleting sensitive
data and data retention there are
safeguards even if data is temporarily
retained it's not as if it can just be
used somebody said it was a mass
surveillance system or something that
isn't what it's about at all some
questioned the ability of the proposal
to tackle serious crime and terrorism
the exchange of information as that has
been said already is not part of this
directive there's only the provisions
that of course there may be exchanged
Denmark and France are those member
states who are part of pilot projects
already retaining passenger name records
and it hasn't helped em ep's have until
the end of March to put forward their
remarks and amendments